que es cartografía oficial es un mapa
una nueva perspectiva de creación de
mapas en la ciudad de toronto que se dio
a partir de la celebración de los 150
años de confederación de canadá y
también porque el accord organización a
la que trabajó estaba cumpliendo 25 años
a cámara germán una de las personas que
estuvo desde la fundación de la
organización o desde muy antes ella
siempre visión o el crear un proyecto
que refleja hace un poco lo que hacemos
en la organización que fuera comunitario
y también que fuera no médico que se
moverá en diferentes partes de la ciudad
así que hay a partir de esa idea nació
lo que es cartografía seventeen que
intenta crear un nuevo mapa de toronto
teniendo la contribución de las
comunidades indígenas canadienses y
también hablando específicamente de los
barrios donde nosotros trabajamos que
son zonas marginalizadas de la parte
norte que es norte o la parte del norte
de toronto trabajando con el toronto 1 y
housing del disidente y trabajando con
diferentes organizaciones hicimos para
los chips
involucrar a muchas personas de las seis
diferentes municipales por anteriormente
llamadas municipalidades del norte org
tópico fiscal e histórico y ahora al
otro no para nosotros era muy importante
que todas las personas de todos los no
tuvieran la oportunidad de unir sus
voces así como porciones de diferentes
zonas teníamos a mujeres a
sobrevivientes de violencia doméstica y
maltrato sexual tenemos también a
personas de saunders tenemos a personas
que estaban saliendo de las cárceles
trabajamos también con emigrantes
trabajamos con los jóvenes con niños con
ancianos este proyecto se llevó a cabo
por personas de toda la comunidad pues
un antes de los 4 años hasta los 104
años participaron 100 años este proyecto
simboliza mucho y significa mucho porque
le dio la oportunidad muchas personas de
que contarán sus historias a partir de
sus dibujos de sus barrios de sus
esquinas de los sitios que lo hacían
emocionar que los ponían contentos que
los hacían felices de quiénes eran ellos
y la identidad que representaban esos
barrios y cómo izaban la bandera de esa
manera tuvimos la oportunidad de
trabajar con 259
en este proyecto que se hizo en toronto
y la forma que ustedes pueden participar
para este proyecto es simplemente el
enviándonos
y sus ganas de ver este proyecto y les
podríamos invitar a alguno de los
diferentes puntos de la ciudad donde
este mapa está en estos momentos
en exposición